good morning believe nation today's
message is be a lifelong wonder yeah
keep on sick how to be how to be a life
on Earth it's be a life long minute --iv
you're giving me a life long learner
yeah good morning believe nation today's
message is be a lifelong learner over to
you Satya Nadella I think more than
anything else perhaps what's defines me
is and this I've also understood exposed
is I'm a lifelong learner I get
energized when I see people achieve high
standards in anything at work when
somebody comes to me with an idea that
they have implemented and it's something
that I've not seen before that's the
thing that gets me going I you know as I
say I buy more books than I can finish
I sort of sign up for online courses
more so than I can actually finish them
but I love it and thank God for these
new online courses where they even have
10 minute segments so at least a a sense
of accomplishment as much easier
cliffnotes yeah I wish I had it when I
was growing up but I think that that is
perhaps more than anything else that
gives me the energy and it's not just
the learning for learnings sake well I
think we all in business in particular
thrive in is applied learning to be able
to take that create products create
programs approaches to how we work with
customers and partners and excelling in
them and being able to sort of both do
that and more importantly learn from
others who are doing it is what I would
say defines me the most so when you
think I know I'm gonna go a little bit
on a different side of it and say that
you know you need to pick what you're
willing to learn I think that there's a
little bit too much information
sometimes that we're overwhelmed with so
focus is important so for me for example
I use Flipboard now subscribe to the
psychology sales and so it will you know
aggregate a bunch of different articles
that I read
I'll do it when I'm in the bathroom with
my tablet I'll do it in the morning if
I'm reading a cup of coffee but just
beast your time is important right
that's the most important thing so value
the fact that when you choose to learn
something when you choose to focus on
something that it's actually going to
enrich you in some way information for
informations sake really is not always a
great thing though it keeps the mind
active
so just value your time and focus on
what will help you grow when I took from
the video was the I like the lifelong
part and I think a lot of people mail it
in I think a lot of people when they're
younger they have emissions they have
Drive do you want to do great things and
then you know maybe they get stuck in
this corporate job or stuck on some path
and they don't know how to get off and
it becomes harder and harder to get off
because now you're married now you have
kids you have a mortgage you of other
responsibilities and then you just you
just mail it in where you stop enriching
yourself you stop learning you stop
trying to be better you give up on your
dreams and I think that's really sad I
don't know that's not most of the people
watching because believe nation is about
taking action being an entrepreneur I
think the lesson that I take from it is
to always be introducing things into
your environment to push you to do more
and be better right that's why I did the
top ten series because I was in a point
in my life and my business where I felt
the people around me weren't pushing me
enough to want to do more and learn more
and do something bigger like much bigger
not just a little bit bigger but like
way up here I want to play way up here
how do I get there I got to hang out
with the people who are doing that and
the closest I can get right now is by
watching their videos in interviews so I
do that every single day and they push
me to want to do better and I might come
to meetings with you know people who
might be my friends or just
acquaintances and they don't know what
I'm talking about because I'm playing at
some other crazy level and they think
I'm off in some dodo land I remember
when we first started working together
you know you thought I was full of these
crazy ideas and like how we're gonna
make this work and grounded in
practicality and now we'll bring in Alex
up to think bigger and stretch and so I
think you need that you need you need to
introduce things into your environment
that make you want to do more than what
you're capable of doing now because
often we don't have the people to push
us
to stretch and then you stay inside your
safe comfort zone and then your flame
slowly dies and I don't want that to be
you that's that's super sad
so keep the stretch so the question
today today is what are you learning
right now I love it as as if I came up
with it myself leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what you guys say
we'll join in the comments thank you so
much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso